So let's get started by looking
at the example Roman discussed.
The awesome thing about this is that
most of the logic lies in the layout
file and
the Java code stays pretty tame.
The only time you refer to
the collapsing toolbar layout is here,
where we assigned the title.
Collapsing tool bar layout allows us to
set the title style when the tool bar
is expanded or collapsed.
We'll explore in a moment
why this is useful.
So, let's take a look at
another food inspired app.
As we can see, we don't have to be
limited to a solid background when
dealing with a collapsing toolbar.
When you scroll,
the image disappears and
the word eclairs appears in the app bar.
The interesting bits about this
image view are right here.
We want the image to have
a parallax effect as it collapses.
That's to say that the foreground
moves faster than the background,
providing a sense of depth to the scene.
In this layout we have a text view
whose content takes up a lot of space.
We would expect to need
to use a scroll view.
Without this line, the app doesn't
know when to scroll the toolbar, so
your toolbar remains stationary.
This is because AppBarLayout
expects to have a sibling
in CoordinatorLayout that is
capable of nested scrolling.
You can do that with a nested scroll
view from the support library, or
by setting
nestedScrollingEnabled to true.
The nestedScrollingEnabled property
is only present on scroll view for
Lollipop and above.
Nested scrolling works with
CoordinatorLayout to notify and
manage when the app bar
should be scrolling,
the nested view should be scrolling,
both should be scrolling, or none.
Check the instructor's notes for
some resources on AppBarLayout.